[موسيقى]
ما ان وقف النظام المصرفي السوداني على
قدميه حتى نكسه شهر من الحرب حرب اعاقت
نظاما كان بالكاد يتنفس سعداء بعد عشرين
عاما من الترنح وتصنيف السودان كدوله
فقيره
انظمه معطله لا كهرباء تنجدها ولا شبكه
انترنت تصلها باصحاب الحسابات ارصده مجمده
حتى اشعار اخر يقفون طويلا امام الفروع
المصرفيه تطول الساعات تحت قيض حارق وقد
يعودون بخفي حنين فحتى الموظفون لا
يستطيعون تشغيلها بسبب القتال وربما
يترددون اليها لايام لان عمليات النقل
الاموال توقفت وبالتالي لا يمنحون الا
عددا محدودا من العملاء كميه قليله من
النقود اما احد فروع البنك المركزي
فالتهمته السنه اللهب وتعرض اخر لعمليه
نهب وسرقه والسليم من المصارف فقد الاتصال
بادارته التي تعطي الموافقه على العمليات
ما يشي بان كسادا يحلق باقتصاد السودان
المكون من 37 مصرفا بينها اربعه مملوكه
للدوله تتحكم في 14% من الاصول المصرفيه
وسبعه مصارف اجنبيه تتحكم بثلاثه وعشرين
في المئه من الاصول المصرفيه بحسب صندوق
النقد الدولي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات